antonio tiene dos veces la edad de su
hermano carlos carlos tiene cuatro años
dalia tiene tres veces la edad de
antonio
la pregunta es qué edad tienen dalia y
antonio vamos a empezar vamos a hacerlo
poco a poco veamos antonio tiene dos
veces
antonio tiene dos veces la edad de su
hermano carlos ok esto es importante
porque carlos tiene cuatro años
dalia tiene tres veces la edad de
antonio la primera información que
tenemos es que carlos
carlos
tienen 4 años
vamos a poner a antonio con otro color
que tal que antonio antón y vamos a
ponerlo con azul antonio
tiene dos veces
dos veces la edad de carlos es decir
antonio tiene dos veces
la edad de carlos y carlos tiene cuatro
años
si ustedes ya se saben sus tablas de
multiplicar sabrán que 2 x 4 es igual a
8 y también lo pueden pensar como 4 por
2 es igual a 8 incluso una forma más en
la que pueden comprobar que estamos bien
es pensar que 2 veces 4 es igual a 4 4
será igual a 8 y con eso tenemos la edad
de antonio antonio tiene dos veces
cuatro años es decir ocho años
y más adelante tenemos para dalia dalia
tiene tres veces vamos a escribir tal ya
dale a tiene tres veces
la edad de antonio y hace un momento
llegamos a la edad de antonio antonio
tiene 8 años
una vez más insisto las tablas de
multiplicar si ustedes saben estas
tablas de multiplicar sabrán que 3 por 8
es igual a 24 8 por 3 es igual a 24 y
con esto quiero enfatizar que se las
deben de saber bueno de principio a fin
define al principio modificando el orden
de los números pero teniendo siempre el
resultado correcto y este es uno de los
conceptos que más van a utilizar en su
vida y que más fácil les hará la vida
saberse las tablas de multiplicar por
favor ahora tenemos que 3 por 8 es igual
a 24 si aún no dominan las tablas de
multiplicar podemos hacer una cosa 8 por
3 también significa que tenemos 18 más
18 más 18 es decir tenemos tres veces 8
88 16 16 más 8 24 y con eso tendremos
que darle a tiene 24 años
cuáles serán nuestras respuestas o qué
queda tiene dalia 24 años de edad tiene
antonio ocho años y nuestro dato inicial
fue la edad de carlos cuatro años nos
vemos en otro vídeo